நான் செய்யவில்லை, மிக்ரோ சைத்தில் நான் செய்யவில்லை, இந்த நடுவில் இருக்கும் மட்டும் நான் செய்கிறேன் என்று நினைக்கிறேன், தெரியாது நான்தான் செய்கிறேன் என்றால்,
அந்த மாதிரி கர்மா, இந்த லெய்ஜஸ் இதை மையமாக வைத்து, அதற்குப் பிறகு நாம் இந்தக் கேள்விகள் செய்யவேண்டும், நாம் செய்யும் கர்மா மட்டும் தனியாக எடுத்துப்போம், மிக்ரோ, மிக்ரோ போகும்போது அனுமதியத்தில் செய்யவேண்டும்,
தரமாத்மா, ஏதோ ஒரு குறிப்பு, ஏதோ ஒரு குறிப்பு, ஏதோ ஒரு குறிப்பு, அது என்ன அதுக்கு மதியாக, நிலையாக, நிலையாக,
அது வீசிமில்லா, உருவம் இல்லாதா, உருவம் இல்லாதா, எனர்ஜியா, எனர்ஜியைத் தாண்டியத்தாவதா,
அது இன்னொரு குறிப்பு, மிக்ரோ, மெக்ரோ, இந்தவட்டு நம்முடைய எளவள், நான் எஞ்ஜினியர், நான் யூக்டியூபர், புரிவிசர் அப்படிக்கொள்வது மாதிரி, நமக்கு தெரியும் விஷயம்,
இன்னொரு குறிப்பு, மிக்ரோ, மெக்ரோ, இந்தவட்டு நம்முடைய எளவள், நான் எஞ்ஜினியர், நான் யூக்கியூபர், புரிவிசர அப்படிக்கொள்வது மாதிரி,
இந்த விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயங்கள், இந்த விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயங்கள், இந்த விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயங்கள்,
இந்த விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயங்கள், இந்த விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயங்கள், இந்த விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயங்கள், இந்த விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயங்கள், இந்த விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயங்கள்,
காலையில் திரீட்டில் வந்திருக்கிறேன், இந்த விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயத்தை.
விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயத்தைக் கண்டுகிறாய் விஷயத்தை.